that criminalize homeless existence.
Who here knows that in many cities
across the United States it is now illegal
to sit on the sidewalk,
to wrap oneself in a blanket,
to sleep in your own car,
to offer food to a stranger?
I know about these laws because I've watched
as friends and other travelers
were hauled off to jail or received citations
for committing these so-called crimes.
Many of you might be wondering why anyone
would choose a life like this,
under the thumb of discriminatory laws,
eating out of trash cans,
sleeping under bridges,
picking up seasonal jobs here and there.
The answer to such a question is as varied
as the people that take to the road,
but travelers often respond with a single word:
freedom.
Until we live in a society where every human
is assured dignity in their labor
so that they can work to live well,
not only work to survive,
there will always be an element of those
who seek the open road as a means of escape,
of liberation and, of course, of rebellion.
Thank you.
(Applause)